now the fate of about 100 migrant
children who was separated from their
families at the US border with Mexico
remains in question this morning as a
deadline approaches for the Trump
administration to reunite them with
their families a judge ruled that the
reunions must be made by this coming
Tuesday but the government wants more
time the children are under the age of
five the administration admitted this
week it doesn't know exactly how many
children it's separated from their
parents but it believes the figure to be
under 3000 president Trump is spending
the weekend at his New Jersey golf
course Paula Reid is traveling with the
president Paula good morning good
morning well even as the controversy and
confusion continues over reuniting
families the president still believes he
can win on this issue by painting
Democrats as weak on border security and
throwing his full support behind
immigration enforcement we are with you
100% defending its controversial
immigration policies the Trump
administration did a full-court press
this week we will always stand proudly
with the brave heroes of ice and our
Border Patrol as vice president pence
and homeland security chief Kirsten
Nielsen visited ice headquarters in
Washington Friday amid calls from some
Democrats to eliminate the embattled
agency abolishing ice would mean more
illegal immigration his message echoed
comments made by President Trump at a
rally in Montana Thursday the president
has repeatedly said he hopes Democrats
continue attacking ice because he thinks
it will help Republicans at the polls
new platform of the Democrat Party is to
abolish ice in other words they want to
abolish immigration enforcement entirely
that's what they want to do but one
issue that could hurt Republicans in the
midterms this November is a budding
trade war after the administration
imposed a new 25% tariff on 34 billion
dollars worth of products imported from
China that went into effect Friday I
think of this as the president does is a
trade dispute the trade war is long
overdue well call Transco
Whitehouse trade advisor Peter Navarro
claims there is no trade war and says
the administration is not worried about
retaliation even though China has
already hit back with tariffs on US made
goods it's not gonna bother our economy
it's not gonna bother us and if they try
to bully our farmers or anybody else in
this country we're gonna have president
Trump's going to stand up for those
folks in addition to those retaliatory
tariffs China also released a statement
saying the US has launched the biggest
trade war in economic history
Erol now polar we know President Trump
is expected to announce his nominee for
the Supreme Court on Monday he prefers
to do things with a bit of a
reality-show Flair we know that he's
narrowed his choices down to three
finalists who all come with the stamp of
approval from the conservative
Federalist Society but there are
differences between them - what can you
tell us about these potential final
three well these final three really they
represent a larger divide within the
Republican Party because here you have
just having on does kettle age there are
traditional conservatives they have a
long track record on the bench they've
both clerked for Justice Kennedy who
would they could potentially replace but
you're seeing social conservatives rally
around judge Barrett even though she
spent most of her career as an academic
and doesn't have as long a track record
but any of these three judges if they
are appointed they would certainly tilt
the court in a conservative direction
for a generation to come Erol all right
Paula Reid there in New Jersey Paula
thank you and as we've said President
Trump is expected to make his choice
public monday night CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor we'll have live
coverage of that announcement beginning
at 9:00 p.m. Eastern